it's been long reported the Democratic
House Majority Leader Nancy Pelosi has
been against impeachment proceedings
against Donald Trump
that has changed the actions of the
trump presidency revealed dishonorable
fact of the president's betrayal of his
oath of office betrayal of our national
security and betrayal of the integrity
of our elections therefore today I'm
announcing the House of Representatives
moving forward with an official
impeachment inquiry I'm directing our
six committees to proceed with their
investigations under that umbrella of
impeachment inquiry the president must
be held accountable no one is above the
law Pelosi says two reasons convinced
her to launch the inquiry that President
Trump was allegedly asking the Ukrainian
president to investigate Democratic
rival Joe Biden and his son and that the
White House then prevented a
whistleblowers complaint about the
President's request to reach Congress as
required by law
Pelosi is putting aside her fair that an
impeachment investigation would allow
President Trump to mobilize his base
with claims of another witch-hunt
he maintains he's done nothing wrong and
authorized the release of a transcript
of his phone call with the Ukrainian
president zalenski shortly after Pelosi
spoke though Trump tweeted this
fundraising video ready to go containing
carefully curated sound bites from
Democratic politicians suggesting they
were attempting to subvert the will of
the people
if we don't impeach this president he
will get reelected it's time to stop
this nonsense
message amplified by the Republican
leader of the house I realized 2016 did
not turn out the way Speaker Pelosi
wanted it to happen
but she cannot change the laws of this
Congress the exact details of the way
Ford for an impeachment inquiry remain
murky but Pelosi said it will involve
the findings of the six inquiries
already underway into the president's
alleged wrongdoing the announcement may
take the pressure off the Democrats from
their electoral base increasingly angry
about a lack of action against the
president now I think what you'll see
from Democrats is the question is this
gonna be a short process or a longer
process so a short process means we look
we we know what we need to know we're
not gonna do a lot of investigating or
not we're not gonna wait and turn over a
lot of other stones before we have this
in the house to impeach this guy and
then the Senate will either do or will
do whatever it does or doesn't do that's
fine but then by putting it behind Nancy
Pelosi all of those house candidates
have said their piece and now they can
go on and talk about other issues and
not be hounded about this the inquiry
may also speed up some of the judicial
attempts underway to get key information
from Donald Trump and his administration
that so far remains secret reports say
Trump is determined he will not be the
third president in US history to be
impeached and whatever the short-term
political consequences the opening of
inquiry doesn't mean Trump will
eventually be convicted of high crimes
and misdemeanors Hsieh Burton C al
Jazeera Washington